hey you guys
doing another movie review and we're
doing another
italian movie because i told you guys
that on this flickers of fear series i
definitely wanted to do some more
italian movies
however this one is not a giallo film
and neither is it a slasher film this
one is kind of like
one of the more underrated i guess uh
italian horror films from the late 1980s
this is called the church or la chiesa
if you would rather have it like that in
its native language
so this was directed by michele sawave
who probably best known in the u.s for
doing
stage fright the slasher which came out
uh one or two years prior to this movie
and also for doing one of my favorite
italian horror films of all time
cemetery man or delamorte delamore if
you prefer
which came out in 1990 with rupert
everett
and uh we did a movie retrospective on
that a while back so if you want to go
listen to my thoughts on that you can go
uh see that as well
now michelle sawavi was he was an actor
as well
um he was in stage fright he was in the
first demons which i'm going to get into
because this movie has like
some ties to that film franchise he's
kind of like one of dario argento's
proteges in a way
and he and dario argento actually
kind of co-wrote uh the church and dario
argento also produced it so he did have
a hand in it
now initially the church or the movie
that would become the church rather
was supposed to be the third in the
demons series uh demons being uh the
first one famously which is actually
very good and i'll get around to it uh
in a little while but it's one where
everyone's kind of trapped in a movie
theater
everyone's turning into demons and it's
super gory super fun
uh that kind of thing and that was
directed by uh lemberto bava
and then so they made a second one
demons two obviously
and lombardo bava i guess he wanted to
do
a third one and i guess i don't really
know but i feel like daario wasn't too
jazzed about it or he wanted to go in a
different direction
uh basically he was saying you know
nobody really wanted other than lumber
to bava nobody really wanted a third
demons film like the studio wasn't
asking for it i didn't want to do it
and so basically lamberto bava
eventually went off to do
uh some other [ __ ] he was doing like
some tv movies after that time
so dario they kind of had a script for
what would become demons three i think
it was supposed to initially take place
on an
airplane of all things these
[ __ ] demons on this
[ __ ] plane
that's essentially what it was going to
be but then after a while he was just
like now we don't want to do that so
they brought in michele sawavi who like
i said is kind of
dario's one of his proteges and mikely
sawavi was kind of like i kind of want
this to be
um you know can still have demons in it
it can still have that sort of vague
idea
but he's like i want it to be like a
more sophisticated movie or like a more
gothic uh type of supernatural horror
rather than
the kind of fun punk rock kind of stuff
that had been uh going on in the demon
series which like i said i do recommend
demons one and demons too they're both
super fun movies but this is
um kind of a different thing altogether
although you can see
where the germ of this idea kind of came
from
those movies because much like in the
first demons where
you know every like all these people are
trapped in a movie theater everybody
starts demoning out and they have to
like fight against them
this one eventually gets to a point
where there are a bunch of disparate
people and they're trapped in a
cathedral
and people start demoning out but not in
exactly the same
way so this movie also stars there's a
you know as in a lot of italian horror
productions of this time period
uh kind of has an international cast uh
you got hugh corsi who is a british
actor although
i believe he was born in ghana and he
was actually in uh
highlander uh he was in uh the first
star wars episode one the fate of menace
i can't remember who he was in that but
he's you'll recognize him if you see him
and he was in some doctor who episodes
as well you also have
uh tomas arana who was an american actor
uh actually went on to much greater
things he was uh
in a bunch of movies he was in hunt for
red october uh the bodyguard la
confidential
born supremacy he was in gladiator uh
you know the dark knight rises so he was
in like a [ __ ] ton of stuff you will
recognize him as well
uh barbara cupisti is in this as well
sort of is one of the main protagonists
if you know anything about italian
horror you will recognize her as well
because she was in
a cemetery man later she was in opera
she was also a new york ripper
she actually started out as a dancer but
she
is actually better known as a
documentary filmmaker of all things
which actually i didn't really know
about her so that was something else
that i looked up while i was researching
this
this also stars a very very young asia
argento i don't
know if this was the first movie that
she was in she was only 14
i think when she was in this uh movie
and she has
kind of a large part in it she's like a
main character but
you know she's for sure like a
supporting role or whatever uh also
another guy that you will
recognize uh as one of the priests in
this
is giovanni radicche who was
very famously in the city of the living
dead the guy that had the
you know the drill put through his head
and he was also in house in the house in
the edge of the park and he was uh i
believe he was also in cannibal ferox
so this has kind of like an all-star
cast so
the story behind this there's kind of a
prologue at the beginning
which is set in the middle ages and you
get kind of all these
knights templar type of i don't think
they're knights templar but it was
you know somebody like that and they're
kind of like going around rooting out
witches
in the countryside so they go to this
one village which
you know somebody told them somewhere
was just like teaming with witches
and they find this young woman who the
kind of the signal of her
being in league with satan is she has uh
a cross
kind of like carved into the bottom of
her foot so i guess like stepping on it
is like sacrilegious so that
shows them that she's a satanist or
whatever so they're basically like
burn it all down and like [ __ ] everybody
in this village they start cutting
people's heads off the horses run over
babies it's a massacre
so uh you know so it starts out kind of
kind of brutal and gory like even from
the first
you know scene so they dump all the dead
bodies
into this big pit and then they
basically say okay we're going to cover
this pit up
and then we're going to build a church
over it to like seal in the evil so it's
just kind of like
satanic tupperware kind of [ __ ] going on
we're going to build a big cathedral
on top of it and just kind of keep all
the
demons and keep all the evil like
underneath the earth and everything will
be fine
obviously because it's a horror movie
[ __ ] doesn't turn out to be fine
but you know you know how that always
goes so then we jump ahead
to the modern day or at least the modern
day when this movie was made which was
1989
so in the cathedral you have all these
kind of cranky priests the one
nice priest whose name is father gus who
kind of ends up being the hero of the
[ __ ]
and you have this uh dude that starts
working there whose name is evan and i
guess he's
uh got hired to be the librarian or
whatever so he shows up late
like you know the main priest like who's
this really really old guy with crazy
eyebrows he just kind of like [ __ ]
you know busses balls about it and all
this other [ __ ] so then
he meets this woman that's working there
who she's like uh working on she's
restoring a fresco so i guess she's like
an archaeologist or
art restorer or something like that so
she's been working in there they pretty
much immediately start making
lovey-dovey eyes at each other and fall
into bed pretty much
without even so much as the how do you
do so there's that whole [ __ ] going on
and then it turns out that uh
so asia argento plays a character named
latte and she
is not like a latte like a starbucks
latte it's latte with an o
but otherwise spelled the same so you
know just just saying she's like the
daughter of the
sacristan and so she lives in the church
i guess and she's kind of always like
crawling around and
getting underfoot and whatnot now it
should be noted
that aj argento's character in the
present day she was also present back in
the medieval
era um she was kind of like the sole
survivor
of the town that got massacred you know
what i mean because i guess like the guy
that was he had her
in his sights and he was gonna kill her
and she just like was so cute and
everything that he couldn't
do it so it's not this is much like in
most italian movies it doesn't make a
huge amount of sense like i'm not really
sure
i don't know it's just like a weird
thing but we'll get into that so so
she's
um you find out later that she's kind of
like it's sort of implied
that she might be like the reincarnation
of that little girl from back then
but i don't really know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing i don't know it's
just
it doesn't make any sense but like i
said this is an italian horror movie
don't worry about
it and honestly i will say that this one
looks if you've seen cemetery man you
know which a lot
i feel like a lot of horror fans have
seen maybe this one not so much
but cemetery man is [ __ ] gorgeous
it's like beautiful to look at
and you can really tell i mean michelle
suave has this really
i mean his eye for filmmaking is just
like amazing so this
movie just like drips with [ __ ]
atmosphere and the cathedral that they
shot it
in i think was in uh hungary if i'm not
mistaken
and it's just gorgeous so like all the
interiors are gorgeous like all the shot
framing is gorgeous this is a really
really nice looking
movie um it just got released on blu-ray
a couple years back i think a
company called scorpion did it so if you
really want to see it kind of in
all its glory then i would recommend
getting that because this is a really
really
visually uh arresting film
so basically what you have like for the
first
hour or so of the movie and i would say
i will say that even though there's some
kind of brutality and stuff in the
beginning like in the medieval prologue
or whatever with you know horses running
over people's severed heads and whatnot
then for about the next hour of the film
because this movie is about
hour 45 minutes something like that it's
a little bit kind of slow
but on that didn't really bother me
because it was kind of cool and
atmospheric and everything and it had
like a little bit of uh
you know we're uncovering secrets kind
of vibe you know what i mean so i kind
of liked that
so uh so evan and uh the art restorer
whose
character name escapes me at the moment
but she was i'll just call her barbara
because that's the actress's name
and that wasn't her name in the movie so
she's kind of like poking around doing
her restoration jazz and she finds this
little bit of parchment like in the wall
and it looks like it has some kind of
weird like secret code on or something
like that and evan gets like super
obsessed with it and like trying to
figure out what it says and then he
realizes it's all backwards latin or
something like that and he figures it
out so the thing that he reads on this
parchment basically says something about
like the stone
was the stone with the seven eyes or
something like that so while he's poking
around like down
in the catacombs or whatever he finds
like this big huge
like cement like you know stone cross
it's like embedded into the floor
and embedded in the middle of that is
this kind of round
stone thing that has sort of a goat head
with seven eyes on it so it's and then
he kind of like turns and it's
essentially like a manhole cover
pretty much and he pulls it out and
there's
this big just it looks like a black void
down there and you're meant to assume
that this is uh
where the demons come out and indeed
that is what happens
so there's some kind of creepy [ __ ] that
happens early on
i mean he seems to be like the first one
to get possessed but i do like that they
didn't do
exactly the same thing like they did in
demons where if you as soon as like a
demon like touched you or scratched you
or something like that
then you would like just [ __ ] demon
out yourself but the cool thing they did
about this one was that when you were
possessed
it would the demon would make you see
things and do things that weren't there
so like
they gave you like visions you know if
you looked at yourself in the mirror
sometimes it was you were all [ __ ] up
looking and stuff but
to other people you didn't look like
that so i kind of liked that aspect a
little bit better it kind of left
everything a little more
ambiguous and it kind of left it open
for some more like weirder like
dream like sort of imagery which i
thought was really cool so
basically evan having opened the
portal to hell as one does uh
he essentially gets possessed tears out
his own heart
again as one does but it doesn't kill
him
so i'm guessing like the demon is
emanating emanating
animating him but he's still like
walking around he still looks like evan
he doesn't look
like he looks a little raggedy and like
he needs to comb his hair and stuff
but he doesn't look like you know
[ __ ] evil dead or anything like that
but he starts acting like super super
weird like he comes back to work and he
starts like being an [ __ ] like not
answering people's questions he starts
being a dick to his girlfriend he starts
like beating her around he starts
[ __ ] with uh
latte azir argento's character you know
and kind of
threatening to stab her in the stomach
and all this other [ __ ] and it should be
noted too that the sacristan who is
latte's
father has also subsequently been been
uh possessed by the demons that are
coming out of the
underneath the cathedral so it's kind of
like spreading a little bit like a virus
but as i said it's
it's not as obvious like who's possessed
and who's not other than them just like
do
acting weird and like doing weird [ __ ]
there's a scene too where
uh where barbara as i said that's not
her name in the movie but that's just
the actor's name and i cause i can't
remember what her name was in the movie
but um even though i just [ __ ]
watched it that's my my memories going i
guess
but she where she's like at her house
and
she sees like essentially like a big
demon
devil monster like outside her window
and starts flipping out and
jumps right out the window to escape it
like right through the glass like right
in her [ __ ] nightgown and everything
i'm like
oh damn you go girl she really really
wanted to get away
but like she she ends up running out and
the cops are already there they're like
yeah we traced your call even though it
was like two seconds
previously i was like wow cops are also
on the ball
but yeah so she gets away with that so
you kind of have that
kind of [ __ ] going on and it's weird
because
you think that evan and barbara are like
the main characters because you kind of
follow mostly them
like throughout their dude there's some
scenes with the priest and there's some
scenes with latte and stuff like that
and the sacristan
but mostly it's those two but then after
evan gets possessed then it kind of goes
off in a slightly different
direction like not it's not like a big
tonal shift or anything but it just kind
of goes off like it shifts the focus off
of them
and goes on to other things and at this
point it seems like
toward the end of the movie like father
gus becomes
sort of the hero of the piece because
he's the one that has to figure out like
what the secret is how they can fight it
or anything
but in the interim between those two
things you basically have a thing where
there's a [ __ ] ton of people in the
cathedral for several different reasons
like there's a teacher with a whole
class full of
school kids that are doing a tour of it
there's this woman
who is wearing the world's most enormous
wedding dress and i guess
i thought she was a model just modeling
a wedding dress but i guess she's
getting married like it's her wedding
day but she's not getting married in
this cathedral but they're taking
pictures of her
and they were basically like hey can we
go in and you know take pictures inside
the cathedral maybe she is a model i
don't know i didn't really get it
but they asked her when she was getting
married and she said yeah i'm getting
married today i don't know what it is so
it doesn't really matter but she has
this [ __ ] huge huge wedding dress and
like a guy dressed up like a groom and
a bunch of other people kind of like in
their entourage
there's this weird there's this weird
old couple
where the guy is always like complaining
and calling his wife an old cow and [ __ ]
like that and she's just like totally
optimistic and oblivious and
saying groovy all the time and eating
the [ __ ] communion wafers and
[ __ ] which they're delightful so yeah so
then you have all of these people
in the cathedral for whatever reason
including all the priests and [ __ ]
and it so happens that the sacristan
who as i said has also been possessed
he realizes that he's been possessed and
has the presence of
mind to go down to where there's some
work being done
in the cathedral and he commits suicide
in probably the most painful way
imaginable by
impaling himself on a running jackhammer
which fair play i don't think i've ever
seen that in a movie before
and it's uh it's quite something but
yeah so you do see like it's just coming
out of this middle there's just like
chunks and it's like
it's great so it's an italian movie so
there's a lot of gore not as much
as some other movies like in this of
this era not as much as demons for
example
but it does have some really good gory
set pieces it's just most of them
you know it it doesn't happen until like
toward the end of the movie you know
what i mean
most of the first hour hour 10 minutes
is kind of more building up of
atmosphere there's a couple gore scenes
but not that many
if you're gonna wait for all the crazy
[ __ ] and all the gory [ __ ] that's like
pretty much in the last like [ __ ] 20
minutes or whatever
so just an fyi so the sacristan killing
himself
with the jackhammer as i mentioned it's
quite awesome somehow
i think that his suicide
causes this mechanism it's very tomb
raider
it causes this mechanism to basically
turn on like in the church and it makes
the front doors close now apparently
this church only has
one entrance and hence only one exit at
least
that anyone ever knows about so when
these doors close everyone is
essentially like trapped inside
uh trapped in the door is the woman with
the enormous
wedding dress because the dress is so
big and she was standing in front of the
door when they were taking the picture
and it kind of and so it's kind of like
sucking or she can't breathe or whatever
and they don't really want to cut it off
her because they're like man this dress
is so expensive
it's just so expensive we have to return
it so uh you know they don't really want
to cut her out right away
so there's that whole issue so so during
this scene where everyone's trapped in
there
everybody starts like slowly starts
getting possessed because like the
sacristan like runs through there and he
like scratches a couple people much like
in demons where you get scratched or
whatever and then that like
demons you out but um so some of those
people start
having visions as well like one this one
guy oh there's also like a
teenager like a pair of teenagers like a
couple or they're not teenagers really
they're probably in their 20s
but they were on their way to a concert
and they ended up in the cathedral
somehow like to make a phone call or i
don't know
and they like he sees his girlfriend
naked
like in the arms of this big demon like
a
big demon gargoyle looking thing who i
think is evan painted green
with big wings now that i'm thinking
about it but yeah i'm not real sure
but yeah so so he sees that there's uh
the woman in the wedding dress she
finally gets
released uh you know from the dress and
she
is kind of down in this thing and she's
real vain so she's kind of like
i can't believe there's not a mirror i
have to see if i look okay or whatever
and she looks in the mirror
and it makes her look like an old hag so
she basically tears her own face off
uh the old people this is my favorite
the old couple
for whatever reason decide they're gonna
climb up to the bell tower i don't know
if they're looking for a way out or if
they're trying to like
hit the bell to like call for help or
something like that i think that's what
they're doing
but so they go up there and like the
dude is all cranky and [ __ ] and he's
just like
she's just like oh whatever just be
groovy i have an idea
and then the next scene you see that she
has
torn off the old fart's head and has
ranked the bell
with a separate head and it's just and
she looks like super duper jazzed about
it
it's so great but yeah i love that so uh
you know and then there's another like
one of the school kids
i think he has a vision that like one of
the other kids is like his doppelganger
or something like that
so all kind of like [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
happens there's demon rape
there's uh this inexplicably this big
pile of naked people
that are covered with mud kind of come
up out of the floor
which i'm assuming are all the people
that the that they killed back in the
old days
you know what i mean and like put him
underneath the thing so i get but like i
said i don't know
i i don't really get if yeah those
people
in back in the middle ages were actually
satanists and witches and they were bad
and so it was okay
for the knights to have killed them and
buried them
and built the church on top of them or
are we saying that the nights were bad
and then i don't know it's it just like
i said i'm thinking about it probably
way too much but yeah so there's
all these naked people like it looks
kind of like a society
actually that uh brian yesterday film it
looks like the shunting
a little bit uh but it's just good it's
not really explained it's just kind of
like yeah here it is
so it turns out that what you have to do
is that when this church was built
initially
over the satanist's mass grave or
whatever
the architect who is the only person
whose tomb is in this church which they
kind of refer to a couple of times
during the movie
they ended up killing him like the
you know the knights or whatever they
ended up after the church was done
they ended up killing him and sealing
him in a tomb
and he so he has this like scroll or
whatever that's like in his mouth
and then there's this other [ __ ] that's
in his mouth it's like a mechanism
and they're basically like if somebody
ever
dicks around and opens this the cross
thing with the stone with the seven eyes
on it and lets the demons out
then somebody needs to go into the
architect's mouth in the tomb
turn this little crank that's sticking
out his like skull face
and bring the whole cathedral down
to keep the demons from escaping into
the wider world
now there is kind of a thing between
father gus
who is a good guy and he's like the hero
and
the cranky old crazy eyebrow uh head
priest dude
who for some reason he know he finds out
about it because he finds like the
scroll or whatever that was
that was hidden and he's like well i
think it's a good idea though like for
the demons to get released in the world
because the world sucks
and i think that that that they're
getting what they deserve [ __ ]
so he's just gonna not do anything and
he's gonna let the demons
out the church and just like run rampant
all over the world because
he thinks everybody deserves it like
it's judgment or whatever
so father guys is like yeah that's i
don't like that idea too much
but basically so what he has to do is
he's just gonna have to bring the whole
cathedral down and kill
everybody in it everybody can't get out
just to keep the demons from escaping
i forgot to mention too that one that
another great scene
like when everyone is trapped in this
cathedral and you know they're trying to
get out and there isn't really another
way out is that the
couple they managed to find this sort of
like way down to this well or whatever
but then they're like oh well
you know this is a dead end we can't get
out but then they find out that it's
like oh there's you know a space under
the floor and it's like maybe the floor
followed so we can get out that way
so they do and like the floor kind of
crumbles under them and they're like
whoo there's like a way out
and then they're just kind of hanging
there in space and it turns out
that that space under there is a subway
tunnel
so like the woman she's hanging under
her boyfriend's hand like
don't drop me don't drop me and then
like a train comes and splat
and it's just i really like that effect
because i like that they didn't just
make it look like a big splattered
you know like a big splattered lasagna
or whatever like on the front of this
train
it's like it still kind of looks like a
face but it looks like it's i don't even
know what it looks like it's made of
it's like really really hard to describe
because it still like looks like a face
but it's like you know what i made it
like over the glass of this thing it's
so awesome but yeah i love that
and i forgot to mention that that uh
happened as well because everyone like i
said is trying to find a way out of this
church because apparently there's only
one door so
uh father gus ends up he doesn't
actually push
uh the old priest fart out of the window
like to his death
but it just kind of happens anyway it's
sort of like an accident so
you know but win-win and uh father gus
decides okay well
i have to go down and go to the
architect's tomb and you know turn the
crank and
bring the whole [ __ ] thing down on
everybody to keep the demons
out of the city which he is apparently
successful in doing
now the only person that survives all
this because everybody that was in the
church that didn't manage to get out all
got smushed okay so
there was that hole so everybody dies at
that and pretty much spoiler alert
uh but the only person that gets out is
again ozzy argento's character
latte you see at the end that the
cathedral
it's it didn't completely fall apart
because you know they're filming
they're obviously not going to knock
down a real cathedral like from for a
movie uh and the one they were filming
in like i said was in hungary but they
did manage to find one that was kind of
like
ruined or like crumbling or whatever
that was in a different part of uh
you know i don't know where that one was
but so they're showing that one as
though
you know hey the tower is still there
but they're gonna rebuild it and there's
all this kind of like [ __ ]
caution tape and the [ __ ] around it and
then at the very end
you see that latte has
she kind of comes to the ruins and she
sneaks in through the fence and she
leaves some flowers there and the looks
it has like a picture of her mom and dad
like her dad was a sacristan and her mom
worked at the church too
so i guess they had an apartment in
there and she lived there so she's like
you're led to believe that she
left the flowers there for her parents
who died when the cathedral fell
but then she finds the stone with the
seven eyes on it right and she's like
huh i kind of wanted this she like
does all the dirt off it or whatever and
then this big trunk goes by
and it kind of pops off and then there's
like this
big shiny blue light in there which is
the same thing that happened when evan
first found the [ __ ] like when the
big cross fell out of the floor or
whatever and then she looks in there and
she's just and then she smiles
so i don't so is latte even though she's
the one that helped father gus
figure out how to smash the cathedral
i mean you would think if she was a bad
guy like if she was one of the original
satanists like or if she was like a
reincarnation of one of the original
satanists
you'd think that she wouldn't want the
she wouldn't want the cathedral
destroyed because she would want the
demons
to run around all over the earth right i
mean that's what you'd think
but so i'm not really sure if she's
supposed to be a good guy or a bad guy
because she did help father gus hey
let's you know you have to go down there
to the tomb and like
destroy the cathedral so the demons
don't get out and then she knew a way
out because she lived in the cathedral
her whole life so she got out
but i don't know so at the end she just
was like smiled so i don't maybe it just
means she's possessed or i don't know
like i said i'm thinking about this way
too much and it's an italian horror
movie but that's just kind of what i do
but yeah so this one
if it's not a jala movie like i said
it's not a slasher
uh but if you like kind of real
atmospheric
gothic sort of horror it uh you know
spiced up with
uh liberal amounts of gore which this
actually does have although like i said
you gotta wait till like the last 20 30
minutes before it gets real
crazy and gets real gory and stuff um
this is not
my favorite movie of mikely suaves um
that would be cemetery man
and actually i think i even like stage
fright a little bit better well i don't
know though i like stage fright as well
that's more of a slasher
um that's kind of a classic and i feel
like this one
this one was made in between uh stage
fright
and cemetery man i think he also made
another one called the sect which is
kind of similar to this one but i
haven't seen it in a long time but i
might get around to that one eventually
as well but yeah so this one is a little
bit of a different thing
it's kind of like demons in the sense
that
it's a bunch of people trapped in an
enclosed space with demons possessing
people
but there's a little bit different uh
kind of vibe to it it's more of like
much more atmospheric much more gothic
that kind of thing
i've seen a lot of people compare it to
john carpenter's prince of darkness
uh which it definitely does have that
kind of vibe to it it doesn't have like
that scientific
uh veneer over it like prince of
darkness has but i can definitely see
the similarities and john carpenter was
a big fan of italian movies particularly
jello movies and prince of darkness has
a little bit of a giallo vibe
to it and a little bit of a jello look
to it so
is so if you like prince of darkness you
might like this one as well
like just kind of they're not super
similar but the vibe is kind of the same
if you know what i mean
it's just kind of like i don't know
there's something about it that's kind
of similar
so it's and if you're kind of new to
italian horror
this isn't where i would start but
it's a really really good and i think
under appreciated
sort of second tier italian horror
particularly italian supernatural horror
uh if you like demons you might be a
little disappointed this one's not like
as
crazy or as fun as that one because i
feel like demons and demons too are kind
of more like
just wacky fun more evil dead type of
things whereas this is more kind of like
a serious
uh you know gothic sort of thing but
if that sounds like something that you
would like then by all means check it
out like i said there's a blu-ray that's
out
uh from scorpion releasing i think
they're called
but if you are a cheap [ __ ] like
i am
uh you can also watch this movie as of
this recording
for free on to be with commercials
but not that many so if you just want to
check it out one afternoon and you don't
have anything better to do then head on
over to tubey.tv and watch it
and uh yeah it's a pretty decent entry
into the italian horror
genre so check it out if you haven't
seen it and that'll do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one bye